[Musique]
je suis Cassandra Brie je suis ingénieur
bureau d'études oui frange et ça prend
lundi system devant moi on a la roue de
la 320 et on a le frein de la 320 donc
faut savoir que ce frein là de la 320 va
venir s'imbriquer dans la roue on a les
différentes encoches qui vont venir se
glisser dans les différentes trous qu'on
voit ici on a ici un empilement de
disque un moment donné le pilote va
vouloir freiner donc il va appuyer sur
la on a les différents pistons
qu'on voit ici qui vont venir se
rapprocher du premier disque l'ensemble
va venir se serrer et on va venir
frotter les différents disques entre eux
et puis l'avion va freiner
qui est innovant dans ce système là
c'est les disques qui sont en carbone
historiquement on avait des freins qui
étaient en acier sur les avions un des
gains majeurs de ce frein qui est en
carbone c'est le gain de masse parce que
il faut savoir qu'un frein en carbone
comparé à un frein en acier on est sur
un gain de masse pour un cours courrier
d'environ 300 kg si on prend en
considération que sur la vie d'un avion
1 kg de masse économisée c'est 10 tonnes
d'émissions de CO2 en moins si on fait
un petit calcul ça nous permet
d'économiser sur la vie d'un avion
environ 3000 tonnes d'émissions de CO2
l'avantage du frein carbone se limite
pas à son gain de masse on a d'autres
avantages et parmi ces autres avantages
on a notamment le fait que on peut
réutiliser nos freins quand ils sont
usés c'est à dire que nos disques vont
pas être suffisamment épais pour
garantir un freinage donc dans ces
cas-là on retire le frein
on s'apprend récupère le frein et on va
venir les régénérer c'est à dire qu'on
va venir donner une deuxième vie à nos
disques et après on va les remettre sur
avion donc ça leur fait une deuxième vie
et ça on peut aussi faire une troisième
fois ce qui fait qu'on a une économie
circulaire de nos freins et qu'on
économise aussi nos ressources
[Musique]
Bruno Clerc ça prend le système Vélizy
responsable du département essai de la
division système équipement nous sommes
au sein d'excellabes le laboratoire
dernière génération de Saint-Flour en
système permettant de tester
qualifier les équipements et systèmes
produits par la division par exemple on
va tester tous les équipements de
distribution hydraulique qui contribuent
à l'extension rétraction des trains mais
également les systèmes qui permettent de
gérer le freinage des avions ou la
rotation de la roue le banc d'essai que
nous avons ici c'est un banc
d'intégration système qui nous permet de
valider l'intégration des derniers
systèmes en particulier notre système
eacha électro hydrostatique qui est un
système plus électrique qui permet de
gérer uniquement localement
l'hydraulique et de n'utiliser que
l'énergie électrique de l'avion ce qu'on
voit c'est un train classique d'A320
qui aura les équipements hydrauliques à
la fois de rotation d'ouverture de
trappe fermeture de trappe et
d'extension rétraction et auquel on a on
gère localement en fait la puissance
hydraulique par une moto pompe et un
petit réservoir d'huile tout ça est
alimenté uniquement via l'électricité de
l'avion géré par notre calculateur qui
vient de s'alimenter au juste besoin
quand on a besoin d'effectuer
l'atterrissage ou de fermer les trappes
et de rentrer le train à au décollage on
a plusieurs types de gains dans un
premier gain en masse c'est à dire que
en fait l'avionneur dans le sein de
l'avion n'a pas besoin d'avoir tout un
tuyauterie hydraulique qui vient
alimenter le devant de l'avion le second
gain c'est qu'on est alimenté uniquement
par l'électricité et on vient pas puiser
sur les la partie de l'avion ce qui peut
se passer au sol par rapport à son
électrification c'est on peut imaginer
ce qu'on appelle le it taxi ou roulage
roulage électrique avec l'intégration
d'un moteur électrique dans la roue
avant ou également dans les
atterrisseurs arrière qui permettent à
l'avion
d'être autonome sur son roulage de ne
plus utiliser la puissance des moteurs
lorsqu'il est au sol et d'utiliser ce
petit moteur électrique intégré dans les
roues les défis de demain c'est là où on
a un système hybride électro
hydrostatique le défi de masse peut-être
sur un système purement électrique ou là
on a plus on aura plus d'hydraulique
mais simplement des actionnaires
électriques dans quelques semaines le
ban que vous voyez derrière moi sera
transformé pour on va tester sur un
plateforme d'avion d'affaires un système
complètement électrique